le débat sur le mariage pour tous
s'ouvre à l'assemblée nationale ce mardi
dimanche entre 125 milles et 408
personnes étaient dans les rues
parisiennes pour clamer leur soutien ce
projet de loi et dans le cortège des
étudiants du syndicat unef et du
syndicat lycéen une aile parmi eux des
illinois partis en fin de matinée de la
gare de versailles chantiers comme
sébastien étudiant au lycée hôtelier de
saint quentin en yvelines ce n'est pas
sa première manifestation et ce combat
s'inscrit dans les valeurs de son
syndicat s'est toujours battu contre les
discriminations que ce soit les
discriminations face au racisme les
discriminations
face au au sexisme et aussi les
discrimations face à l'homophobie et
aujourd'hui on est dans la rue parce que
toute avancée sociale qui permet de
dison banaliser l'homosexualité à la
société c'est un progrès pour nous c'est
pour ça qu'on est là pour défendre ça
c'est important de montrer que le projet
du gouvernement compte qu'il est soutenu
par une grande majorité de la population
les étudiants divinement ans rejoint le
gros de la troupe sous une bannière
commune unef une aile il était environ
10000 à défilaient parmi les autres
manifestants
une mobilisation qui a convaincu
sébastien il s'est dit satisfait tout en
déplorant le manque de couverture
médiatique quant aux opposants au
mariage pour tous il ne baisse pas les
bras samedi le collectif illinois la
manif pour tous appellent à se
rassembler à 15 heures devant la
préfecture de versailles pour demander
le retrait du projet de mariage
d'adoption et de procréation
médicalement assistée